either settled out of ass and open
everything baby think I still go to the
NBA
I'm cueing the baby
[Music]
the lady at the front dancers children
there's life out of Sunday's coma just
make sure y'all don't be too rough room
and make sure I don't have a camera
silence please
just shooting like he's a regular person
only thing that was on the line was
winning
[Applause]
people like this Chancellor trash me
news that Jen I went out Joe said I'm
your little took a bad shot in the
playoffs for the win
I mean I know bash I need to go in
nothing you can shoot back there we go
and there's a good shot
I mean he's such a regular dude you
another think he'll superstar a movie
star or nothing he'd come in the gym
with baggy clothes and stuff you won't
even know it you would never think much
of it so I'm really like I didn't think
like I said I didn't think much or too
after a fatal shot on out of the sand
over here I had chemo money the baby go
you watch the bleacher report